it took at minimum
756 days and at most a decade depending
on who you ask
but it finally happened the world is
once again living in a true
uncontested
navi era this past weekend esl pro
league season 14 came to a close and
with it season three of the intel grand
slam now simple took home his share of
the milli
but that's not all that happened
zai wu had a much needed resurgence
and liquid
well let's just
let's just not talk about it
i'm kidding
let's talk about all of it
[Music]
before i start openly weeping on camera
as refresh makes his way over to new box
i'm going to ask that all of you
beautiful counter-strike adoring kings
and queens
like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on the
notifications
for zywu since i weirdly started
speaking french okay so on sunday we
beheld the truly epic conclusion of esl
pro league season 14.
and let me tell you this event
went hard it was everything we'd hoped
for and more i was blown away the only
thing that got railed harder than my cs
go loving soul
was flom's viewership dimitri dude hey
dmitry i will [ __ ] ban you bro i
swear to god anyway the main reason that
this tournament was so important was
because of simple navi
and this little thing called the intel
grand slam an epl final is always a big
deal but this one was an especially big
deal for the boys in yellow in fact
it was downright historic for those who
aren't aware intel's grand salami is a
super prestigious million dollar circuit
award bestowed onto the first cs go
roster to win six esl pro tour masters
events in a span of 10 consecutive
events or 4 in a span of 10 if inclusive
of a cologne katowice or major now shy
of winning a major securing a slam is
just about the single most gangster
thing one can achieve in counter-strike
in fact prior to this event only two
teams had ever managed to pull it off
astralis in 2018 and team liquid in 2019
suffice it to say going into this
tournament navi were hellbent on
becoming the third since
well let's be honest they had a [ __ ]
rough 2020. after kicking off the year
with a very dominant performance at iem
katowice one that was supposed to
initiate a navi era of sorts
covet hit everything went online and
simple's roster fell off kind of hard he
himself even narrowly lost the hltv
number one to his greatest rival
zywoo who we'll get to later that said
pretty much as soon as 2021 rolled
around navi went on a tear simple was
back to being the greatest player alive
bit the youngin they brought in was
firing on all cylinders and the roster
was finally working as intended winning
cologne 2021 and dreamhack master spring
before setting their sights on season 14
of epl as expected they beat ens and
heroic to make it all the way to the
finals where they faced off against
zywoo and vitality in a back and forth
bout for the ages
navi did end up clinching it of course
and if you haven't seen the winning
moment
you should since it was very wholesome
only zy who can deny the intel grand
slam navi a couple of bullets is all it
takes and there it is
their domination is secured
[Music]
and i think their reaction says it all
so much hard work popped into this one
intel grand slam in the back
so what does this mean
well it means that for the first time
since the tail end of 1.6 navi are
incontrovertible the initiators of a
true uncontested era a lot of you may
not know this but navi actually made it
to the grand finals of six of the last
seven majors the original counter-strike
ever had
four of which they won consecutively so
for navi and die hard fanboys such as
yours truly
this win was a long time coming
but it was an even longer time coming
for simple in addition to
pretty much solidifying his spot at the
top of hltv's top 20
simple is now the recipient of a grand
slam which means that csgo's dearly
beloved goat has now won pretty much
everything there is to win in
counter-strike shy of that ever-elusive
major his work is cut out for him
and he knows it
okay i need new haters the old one
became my fans
that's nice yeah there you go yeah it's
pretty much as easy time to talk about
haters i want to talk about fans
i need new haters the old ones became my
fans
this man is a [ __ ] king
it was also great to see not only zywu
back in fighting form but vitality as a
whole vitality's issue has always been
what navis was a few years ago which is
that if their star fragger doesn't drag
their lifeless corpse across the finish
line
they'd get hosed
this time they didn't just slam they
slammed together
they know where you are and he was
tagged up earlier he's calling for
backup done well to take another and
they're dropping like flies it falls to
cyber with an adjustment of his own and
sharks to be peaked in this shot from
bit but there goes
shocks has to do it all now
they're posted up on his location using
the smoke for the element of surprise
and he floats like a butterfly stings
like a bee so what else happened that's
worth talking about well aside from
gambit putting up yet another
semi-disappointing result and og
knocking out nip
there's
well
do we have to talk about it
we do
all right apologies nacs fans because
it's time that we talk about liquid you
see while our valorant brethren were off
having a ball in berlin all weekend
kicking ass and taken names
we counter-strike stans had to watch as
na's only team faced off against heroic
in a barn burner so ballistic i want to
scream
sigh
and cry
just thinking about it here is the quick
and dirty of it series starts off on
overpass where after going down eight to
one liquid rally 11 rounds on ct to
close it out 16-12
they proceed to lose a squeaker on nuke
before going to inferno where they find
themselves down 12 to [ __ ] three at
the half suffice it to say
it's over gg it happens
unlucky
go next
the thing is
it wasn't over liquid proceed to win 12
out of the next 14 rounds executing some
of the tightest cleanest boston major
tier ct rounds i have ever seen elise
waiting in the library he's going
through elise mows them down he's trying
to save n.a he's trying to save the day
and grim from pit locks it in 15 14
liquid a misread but the adjustment is
immediate and then right as they find
themselves up 15 to 14 on match point
with heroic's mental absolutely chalked
beyond repair
this happens
kind of thing still we have fallen
making it happen make it team liquid be
that semi-final he's three fresh as good
as he's been as much as he's given us
this is a team liquid victory team up
he's on for a third now i did as well
refresh how are you making this happen
grim the pit hero the guy who's dug deep
throughout this entire series to save
that a bomb site has now gonna come in
clutch and b
refresh on for the ace in a one-on-five
clutch
grim his heart's racing his heart's
beating but refresh can't find him it's
your guessing game stick on the bomb
grim doesn't swing he thinks it's a fake
refresh with all five and we're going to
overtime needless to say liquid could
not come back from a choke like that
no one could come back from a choke like
that they lost in overtime in what has
to be one of the craziest matches i've
seen in
i don't know man ever i don't want to
think about it anymore is refreshes 1v5
up there alongside the cadian clutch as
not only a shoe-in for play of the year
but one of the all-time greats
yes
did it haunt me as i lay in bed that
night and make me want to shriek into a
pillow
yes
now to be clear i am not going to sit
here and take liquid to task over a
misplay that catastrophic
and nor should you
they're gods of the game they know how
badly they messed up
they don't need you to tell them
or me suffice it to say they played
things way too safe froze up and allowed
refresh to take five consecutive 1v1s
that he never should have had
what they should have done was execute
what smooya rightly termed the 3-2-1
swing this dude maneuver and clapped him
but they didn't still that was some of
the finest counter-strike we have seen
from liquid in ages and we should not
lose sight of that over one blunder no
matter how gut-wrenching would it have
mattered had liquid made it to semis
i mean considering that heroic did
actually take a map off navi and
vitality took two maps off them
maybe
the previous grand slam winners standing
in the way of the prospective ones could
have been a storyline
and dare i say should have been all in
all season 14 of upl
absolute banger i'm grateful for every
moment of it
even the rough ones counter-strike is in
an awesome place right now and i for one
cannot wait to see what it's got in
store since apparently
we're getting a real major with the
crowd
see you then
i need new haters the old ones became my
fans
this man is a [ __ ] king
that's such like dude
tell me you're the lebron james of
esports without telling you that lebron
james i mean sports like [ __ ] christ
dude
what a god jesus
my favorite thing about simple is like
how f wording
like just what a gangster he is like how
badass he is and then literally 10
seconds after this before the cast
switches away halting everything to wish
his dad a happy birthday
he's so [ __ ] wholesome i love it dude
oh god i love it